i'm tara santa maria for wired with
Jenna Coleman Matt Smith and Steven
Moffat from Doctor Who
thanks so much for being here guys are
having this so walking away from the
role as the doctor you've been doing it
now for four years yes and what's next
for you no no I'm not even contemplating
that yeah I want to make the last
episode one of the best that we've ever
made and really sign off with a you know
a bang and a wallet Mellon and I want to
enjoy that moment and then we've got the
50th anniversary coming up in November
so there's a lot there's a lot of who
stuff that will take me up to Christmas
and then so that I'm just going back to
being lowly and unemployed what's it
been like working with Matt and what's
next after Matt is gone I mean are you
thinking about that right now
well it's genuinely honestly I've been
after enjoy working with Matt for these
four years absolutely extraordinary a
very very good friend and I don't think
I've ever worked with an actor who is a
you'd agree can our better company
leader so it's been an absolute joy when
were heartbroken
you've been with the show for one year
now you have a whole new doctor that
you're gonna be introducing tender
moment in the relationship where you're
between Boyer that's so tough
responsibility though isn't it to
introduce a new doctor to adoring fans
to say to say farewell yeah that's
what's with us yeah that's what we're
gonna focus on I'm first and you know
Steven is beginning to write the episode
and we just want to make sure it's gonna
be one of the biggest and the best and
the most fitting tribute to the eleventh
Doctor it's one of the joys of Doctor
Who in this eventuate he's you get to
kill him occasionally
yeah it does still add to the Shuar but
you can do a grand finale a magnificent
death and then he just gets up and says
right let's all start at the beginning
again thing about it you know and I see
you for the show it galvanizes it again
it you know it sort of it reawakens it
somehow and i think and then i'll be
i'll be a fanboy it will be very hard
you will remember the doctor all the
other doctors have remained the doctor
you've met David has he given it up in
any sense
dr. Davison still thinks he's the doctor
they are tolerant enough to watch these
imposters on the television yeah yeah
Peter and David both still make Sunday
lunches running that table doctor who
wants so have you guys watched the whole
back catalogue I mean Hawaii how many
hours how many there are three if you
watched the whole of Doctor Who every
episode it would be three hundred and
seventy seventy nine hours 48 minutes
yeah but they don't exist many of them
were wiped so we've lost the longest
definitely attract did you know how many
times the Daleks have said it
exterminate in the whole battle
conditions you actually know that God
you know 79
that seems like a low number I'll try it
are you used to people saying
exterminate frequency for a show that's
been on for so long it is kind of
character but we think of them as iconic
to this fair I mean they're not known
for their big speeches oh thanks
am a Dalek is your guide just kill him
doctor at that point I think they just
want to kill everything L because
everything else has speak fast yeah
I'm second but I've always trying to
tell a joke they get there first let's
exterminate